wayne gretzky arguably the greatest
hockey player of all time said he didn't
skate to the puck but to where the puck
was going ice hockey is a fluid
unpredictable game he couldn't know how
the game would develop so he practices
skating and his stick handling today's
labor market is like that every month
millions of jobs are created and
eliminated technology is changing how
jobs are done at an even faster pace the
skills of today can be obsolete tomorrow
what's a human to do like Gretzky we
should all focus on the basics first as
mastery of reading writing and math
second technological literacy we don't
all need to be coders but we have to be
able to understand and use data and
software third we need to develop our
most human qualities creativity
intuition and empathy don't play any
genes transcend them a dynamic growing
economy creates new opportunities every
day but just like Gretzky we have to
have the skills to take advantage of
them at the skate to where the puck is
going what do you think makes for career
success let us know in our poll also let
us know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI